est-ce que vous allez faire on a bien
essayé d'obtenir leurs commentaires
puis il y a les micros
j'ai pas prononcé ce matin malgré le
malaise de bon nombre de kakis le caucus
dit oui au dépôt d'un projet de loi pour
faire passer leur salaire annuel de 101
à 131000 dollars un tout petit projet de
loi de seulement deux articles question
d'évacuer rapidement le débat sensible
auquel François Lego n'a pas trop envie
de participer en juger par sa marche
rapide
[Musique]
il y a eu un comité indépendant c'est
penché sur le dossier le ministre
désigné pour répondre aux questions le
répète on donne
suite aux recommandations
nous on suit les recommandations du
rapport dans le rapport déposer il y a
quelques semaines un comité composé de
deux excellus et d'un experts en
ressources humaines peut-être qu'il faut
égaler le salaire des hauts
fonctionnaires parce que les élus
travaillent sans relâche dans un
contexte politique de plus en plus
intense
oui ils ont droit à toutes sortes
d'allocations supplémentaires mais ça ne
suffirait plus à convaincre des
candidats potentiels de quitter leur
emploi je trouve que ça envoie un
message de déconnexion pas question de
pour annonce déjà Québec Solidaris
surtout pas en pleine négociation avec
les employés de l'État mais la formation
ne dit pas si elle refusera
l'augmentation des élus craignent la
perception des Québécois qui semble
d'ailleurs plutôt partagé ah c'était
trop de poids
il devrait faire ça à tout le monde
alors déconnecter de la réalité là
rémunération soit proche du privé à
quelque part je pense que c'est un
travail qui est difficile puis ça
demande ça demande beaucoup d'efforts
que je pense qu'il y a une augmentation
de 30000 ça a l'air raisonnable le PQ ne
sait pas encore s'il s'opposera vous
sentez bien qu'on est mal à l'aise on ne
demande pas on n'est pas en politique
pour l'argent le Parti libéral lui est
favorable tant qu'on met en place un
mécanisme
ok indépendant pour cesser d'être jugé
partie à l'avenir mais il s'empresse
d'ajouter ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
a été demandé et pendant que les députés
discutent de leur augmentation de
salaire le cercle des ex parlementaires
profite du momentum et plaide aussi pour
des meilleures conditions après la
politique ici Véronique prince
Radio-Canada Québec